If you've ever taken the time to sit through
the full credits of a movie, you've noticed
that it can take thousands of people to finish
a film—which makes it that much funnier
when a glaring mistake sneaks its way past
all of them.
Here are some of the weirdest, funniest, and
all-around best movie mistakes that made the
final cut.
Star Wars head bonk
Director George Lucas didn't have the biggest
budget to work with when he made the original
Star Wars, so he had to work with some shots
and situations that were less than ideal.
One legendary mistake happens when a bunch
of stormtroopers burst into a Death Star control
room.
One trooper, unable to see well through his
helmet, bumps his head on the door.
Lucas may not have planned the shoot this
way, but when putting together his "special
edition" years later, he didn't take it out.
Instead, he added a sound effect to acknowledge
the goof.
“Take over!”
Elsa’s amazing hair
When you're a Disney cartoon, you don't have
to obey the laws of physics.
Just ask Elsa from Frozen.
During her big musical number, she can flawlessly
let down her hair...and she can even send
her braid soaring straight through her arm
without feeling a thing.
Gotham City’s horrible drivers
Even before Bane took over Gotham in The Dark
Knight Rises, the city had plenty of problems
with criminals—but not just the superpowered
ones.
When Catwoman steals Bruce Wayne's car during
one of the movie's lighter moments, it's amazing
to see that literally no one on the street
is obeying the obvious red light at this intersection.
Holy traffic ticket, Batman...
Captain Waterproof
In Captain America: The Winter Soldier, we
see Cap diving out of a plane into the ocean
so he can stage a sneak attack on a ship—and
when he climbs out of the water, he's bone
dry, shield and all.
He probably learned that trick from the Sub-Mariner.
Batman’s Incredible Bat-Punch
It's easy to forget how much choreography
is involved in a movie fight sequence, but
there's a lot more to it than just pretending
to throw kicks and punches.
One wrong move can mean the difference between
a scene that looks convincing, and one that…well,
looks like the rooftop fight from The Dark
Knight Rises.
There's a lot going on here, including a fateful
turn in the relationship between Batman and
Catwoman.
So most of us didn't notice that one of Bane's
henchmen takes a dive during the fight, falling
down without anyone even laying a hand on
him.
The Amazing Spider-Lamp
The best part of having multiple Spider-Man
reboots is getting to see Spidey learning
how to use his powers all over again, right?
Just kidding!
It's the most boring part of the story.
But in 2002's Spider-Man, our young hero's
training footage comes with a memorable blooper:
he breaks a lamp while testing his webbing,
but when Aunt May comes knocking at the door
moments later, it's back on the shelf like
nothing ever happened.
One possible explanation: it was bitten by
a radioactive lampshade.
Another possible explanation: lazy editors.
Harry Potter and the Visible Cameraman
In one scene from Harry Potter and the Chamber
of Secrets, a tense battle of wands between
Harry and the villainous Draco Malfoy includes
an extra bit of magic...in the form of the
Muggle cameraman who can be glimpsed filming
after Harry knocks Draco down.
Maybe he's there shooting an MTV reality series...Sixteen
and Magic.
The mysterious hedge maze
Stanley Kubrick's The Shining is a masterpiece
that uses disorientation to create a growing
feeling of unease in the viewer.
As Shining experts have pointed out over the
years, the movie's setting—the remote Overlook
Hotel—has a floor plan that's riddled with
spatial impossibilities.
The weirdness doesn't stop at the hotel walls,
either: the movie's climax makes brilliant
use of a creepy hedge maze—which is nowhere
to be seen during the sweeping aerial shot
of the Overlook that opens the movie.
Unintentional goof, or twisted Kubrickian
genius?
You decide.
The little anticipator
One of the greatest goofs in classic cinema
occurs during this scene from the vintage
Hitchcock thriller North by Northwest.
Watch the background during Cary Grant's argument
with Eva Marie Saint, specifically when Saint's
character pulls a gun on Grant.
A child actor, who'd evidently gotten a case
of nerves after reading the script or suffering
through a few too many takes, covers his ears
well before his character is supposed to be
aware of what's going on.
Teen Wolf flasher
There's no shortage of cheesy silliness in
the mid-'80s Michael J. Fox cult comedy classic
Teen Wolf.
After all, it's about a suburban kid who suddenly
realizes he's, you know, a teen werewolf.
Not much subtlety in that title.
But there's a background extra in the movie's
final act who actually is pretty subtle, and
who may give you a quick laugh if you're watching
closely.
The moment in question occurs during the big
celebration after Fox's character wins the
big game, and a celebration erupts in the
stands—evidently surprising one young woman
in the crowd, who can be seen cheering with
her pants completely unzipped and unbuttoned.
She manages to get them closed up later in
the scene.
But, really, let's take a moment to recognize
that a nameless extra managed to become more
interesting than the werewolf who just won
a high school basketball game.
Give that woman an Oscar.
The Commando Porsche
There are so many questions in Arnold Schwarzenegger's
1980s action masterpiece Commando.
Like, why is this big Austrian's name John
Matrix?
And how is Alyssa Milano his daughter?
And more than anything, what's the deal with
his magic yellow Porsche?
We're talking, of course, about the part of
the movie that sees Matrix chasing down the
bad guy, Sully, trashing the Porsche in the
process.
The car seems destined for a few weeks in
a body shop…until John gets back behind
the wheel, at which point it appears miraculously
damage-free.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to see more
videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to tell us your favorite
movie mistakes that should've made the list!